I want people in our audience to have an
understanding of the financial
indicators that are being discussed in
corporate media now that the stock
market is just crashing crashing
crashing everything's flying off the
walls virus oil Japan all of this
different stuff it's important to
understand what people are talking about
the entire yield curve for all federal
US bonds fell below 1% yesterday this is
the first time in history period that
this has ever happened what does this
mean and why do we care let's talk about
it first of all what are US bonds u.s.
bonds are debt securities issued by the
US Treasury so essentially the US
Treasury will borrow money from you if
you loan the government money by buying
a bond the government pays you an
interest rate that interest rate is what
we are talking about when we say the
bond yield there are different bond
durations the big ones that are the
leading indicators are the five year
bond the 10 year bond and the 30 year
bond and the idea is the longer term
bond pays a higher yield why well in
general if you were willing to lock your
money up for a longer period of time in
exchange for that you get a higher yield
a higher interest rate you make more
money for being willing to lock up your
money for a longer duration that's why a
5 year CD with your bank typically pays
more than a 1 year CD looking at the
crash in bond yields over the year so
far and including over the last few days
we see that all three of these bond
yields the 5 10 and 30-year fell below
1% yesterday to the area of 0.4 0.5
percent why is this happening and what
does it mean well with bonds yields and
prices move in opposite directions okay
so imagine you have a hundred dollar
bond that pays one percent when stocks
crash people want bonds because they are
seen as safer they are seen as a sure
bet where you will make something even
if it's only 1% so as people start
demanding more bonds the price of the
bonds in
someone might be willing to pay a
hundred and five dollars for a
hundred-dollar bond or a hundred and ten
dollars for a hundred-dollar bond that
1% interest rate calculated over a
hundred and five dollars or a hundred
and ten dollars is no longer a 1%
interest rate it's less so as people
demand more bonds the price of the bonds
goes up the yield is the same which
lowers the effective yield of the bond
the yield goes down since in uncertain
times people are willing to accept a
lower return because of the relative
safety of bonds over stocks so what we
are seeing here this crash and bond
prices is a rush to safety the virus
news the oil price is crashing the
Italian lock down the Japanese economic
contraction all this stuff makes people
think wow stocks are going to crash
which they are doing I'm going to move
my money to bonds this raises the price
of bonds lowering the yield the yield of
bonds and people are willing to accept
the lower yield if you expect stocks to
do well you wouldn't invest in bonds at
0.5% yield because you'd expect to make
way more money with stocks if you expect
stocks to lose money suddenly a sure bet
of making 0.5 percent on a u.s. bond
starts to look attractive this is a sign
an indicator of absolute and total panic
that the outlook is so negative that
bonds are dropping to these levels this
could be as bad as 2008 or maybe things
get under control in the next two months
and things don't get as bad as 2008 as I
told you earlier in the program I
already outlined what I am doing
financially it was not financial advice
but you can go back to our earlier
segments from today if that is
interesting to you one of our sponsors
is privacy calm they're giving you $5.00
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a life saver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up any time you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman